so
this is what's going on right now with
with xi jinping is this
one party rule so if you're one guy and
you're not willing to take any kind of
criticism
what does that create and this is where
i think our advantage is going to come
because what's going to happen
and i saw this in 2000 um in 2019 when
he um or 2017 when he um
became the sole leader for life
basically
uh i said that's it that's the end that
is the end
and if you look at the speech that you
talked about this breaking heads and
and blood will flow that's xi jinping xi
jinping is going to take the chinese
communist party in a bad
in a bad direction because it's going to
be very militaristic
you know you want to talk about um what
they're doing they're building you know
nuclear weapons they're building
hypersonic weapons they're building
i mean it it is a it is a military
build-up the likes the world has never
seen is going on right now in china
tell us about hypersonic weapons
so i when i was at defense attache in
beijing i sent a couple of my guys down
to
um to southern china to uh what was
called a hypersonics conference in
shaman shaman china
and they they go down there and
um there's like 700 chinese in a room
listening to a nasa scientist talk about
how to build hypersonic missiles
let me tell you what i just pulled up
okay go to google type in hypersonic
weapons hypersonic weapons fly at least
five times the speed of sound
let me see did you hear what i just said
they fly five times
the speed of sound have unpredictable
flight paths
and are expected to be very difficult to
defend against the department of defense
is developing hypersonic weapons and
technologies with support from other
agencies
so they're spending time learning from
america on how to build hypersonic
weapons
the guys go up to the nasa scientists
and they're like do you guys know what
you're doing
like yeah it's science you're teaching
the enemy to build missiles that are
going to be targeted at us
like what are you talking about how is
that a lot like how do people
logically not understand that like what
like who even approves that but what i'm
trying to say is who even approves that
name oh so i mean
so you know technically at the time it
wasn't okay for a nasa scientist to go
over there themselves and so what they
did is they arranged for
some kind of contract so they go over as
a contractor not really as a
nasa official but i mean they're
basically scientists that work for nasa
and so this is
this is what is going on across our
country and this is you know what i
tried to talk about
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you